c'est maintenant acté le festival
pulsations sera organisé à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines le
26 et 27 septembre 2020 l'heure est
maintenant à la réflexion pour trouver
des partenaires mais aussi des artistes
pour créer la programmation l'idée
maintenant c'est donc d'aller construire
complètement festival donc terminée la
programmation musicale préparer tous les
aspects techniques logistiques
sécuritaire évidemment du site pour que
le festival puisse se tenir dans les
meilleures dispositions pendant les deux
journées du 26 et du 27
une plus value pour lille de loisirs qui
accueillera les festivaliers fin
septembre suite à la signature de la
convention
elle montre notre volonté de développer
sur 7 des loisirs les opérations
culturelles pour le grand public
réfléchir aux contraintes de la météo
respecter le milieu environnemental du
parc ou mettre en place un système de
sécurité
ce sont les points techniques encore
avoir avant que le festival pulsations
de s'installe à saint quentin en
yvelines